No. So i thought of.
And i think i'm too close
with well you know.
You know for us. High.
On world thing you know.
And this is going to go awry
how did i come to nimbin.
Was that. Back when the couriers
first it was first happening.
Or even before then actually used to come
down here to go down to byron 30 actually.
Around broken head
and being involved probably from the
60s with the the new age of the hippie
movement of that was then
and being somewhat very radical myself
looking for an alternative in life.
Not being happy with the system
of the rot of the system.
Sort of used to venture around
going to different places
and i can actually remember.
I think the first tour they
have the ties quite a lot.
And decided to come down and check it out.
I came down with a group of friends
living in brisbane at the time
and living in a community how to get me
an old style house a number of us living
there. And we all decide to come
down and see what was happening.
So we came down before the festival.
It was sort of interesting.
You know getting out of a.
Smoking and tripping whatever.
It's always good to get out in the
country especially if you're tripping.
When our 30th sort of it's
nice to get away from people
and you can sort of be relaxed an
environment that you feel safe in
and sort of logic itself get into nature.
So they don't survive as a real bars and
coming down here and it's a nice area
and people seem friendly and
interesting things going on
and they were in the first of all
this happening it was quite a vase.
Just i suppose the people there
apart from the area the land.
I mean it's obviously unique
obviously. It is different.
It has a lot to offer. So i
think the people at the time.
When the first of all is
on it was very colourful.
So if i remember it was
sort of towards the end of
when all the festivals were
happening from the 60s it was
when they started you know
dying out that there.
This aquarius testable happened
and it was interest seeing
it was it could be and they.
The whole town i suppose is hold
a little village being there.
All these shops and things and set
up there a sort of wander around
and help yourselves. You
know. Get out of it.
Sort of you know. The actual hills
around at when the festival was on.
Well it was only virtually directly around
the town itself so you know the people
would sort of mingled around the
hills and camped tense all sorts of.
Unique dwellings a load
of. Temporary drilling.
I suppose that was typical for those
the first two rules of around
that time was to love experimenting looking
searching sort of looking at consistent
new ideas and.
Once sort of interacting
with different people.
Like.
High life high life.
I suppose there was no
one pacific or major one
that i can think oh
this is that i suppose.
The whole essence of the festival in the
feeling of the area was yeah it's nice
it's great you know be nice
to be able to live this way.
You know it's stimulating exciting as.
It's good and sought after the
first or going back to verse and.
The usual stuff where you know have to
fall back into the system in the right
and not feeling happy about
and then go back down to nimbin some
months later to check it out again
that sort of finding it sort of changed
there was even a different feeling amongst
the people. There's some
sort of resentment.
And i think it was to do with you know like
with it with anything is for something
to actually happen it needs
energy to go into it so it needs.
The energy comes from the heart
and therefore if we're not putting the
energy into it then it's not really
happening and the sort of get people that.
They just appear just purely for
what they can get out of it
and don't put anything into it
and because it doesn't work.
You get too many people doing that.
It's just you then start getting resentment
from other people because it's not
enhancing it's not adding to the
whole thing is just taking from it.
I think that's why.
The particular feeling of the place
and was you know the suspicion also you
know of you know you know what do you want
you know what are you doing here. You know
what do you want from us. So there's a.
What you felt.
It was yeah yeah that
was a few months after.
And then i think probably a year a year
and a half after the first of all went
back and the feeling was strongly there.
And it's also the other thing
else when the actual communities
or communes as they were then were forming
and cooperatives the just wondering
how to say forward actually being
and if it would work and trying to
break away from my own. Feelings or.
Conditionings of security in the system.
Breaking away from you know the false sense
of the security of you know having a
job and having money and
having a gun and a house
and you got all the structure around you
that you can hide in the pool or you
and all your friends there. I suppose
you friends on you know and.
Sort of breaking away from that as i
found it was actually very difficult.
And coming to a place where you
sort of did a different creation
and even though it stimulating
exciting there still.
The fear sake try to think of it.
Will i survive in this or relate freakout
or well i lose whatever it is i.
I already have. You can't pull
you through that you know.
To challenge. Yeah i think so.
I find in most of them probably and
also now they have these two aspects
and i suppose. Maybe we all do
or a lot of people do we
have many different aspects.
Whenever it is but there seems to be
these two major aspects and one is
that i can fit into the system
quite easily and play it again
and it because it's easy to do you know
you can just fall into it and so on.
You know you just become
like a clone artist.
But even though it was
easy to do that and to be
that i there's this other aspect
of me that is very radical
and it sort of says you know i need to be
looked at i need to be express you know
this isn't a feeling me
doing this and so i find
when i look look at that aspect of
myself that it wants to challenge all
that it doesn't want to
play by all these rules
that they were created by someone
else that those. That really.
I just i don't know i just challenge
your region it wasn't for feeling in me
so.
Sort of realizing that there's this
aspect of me that i need to feel and.
I guess.
That also covers all that's pretty true
and for oneself in lifestyle sexuality.
The whole life. Plays.
Toast. That's a good
question. I'm not so sure.
It's it's reasonably i find it.
On the one of the groups you know first.
How we're there for field.
No i don't think they are.
Yeah so i guess. I don't really know if
my exit expectations had been for soon.
You know because i finally still questioning
things i still looking at myself
and. What's reflecting back around me.
I further wonder if that's
just an ongoing seeing
or you know like how we
create things around us
and we get caught up in our own creations
and you know the more we put into it.
This gets going on and
maybe we need to drop all.
But.
Just recently i've been looking at how
i feel and with where i am now i hear
and dylan clues and after
being here for 10 years.
And how it's developed and. And.
I find you know looking more into myself
too as to maybe looking at things like
one's own selfishness and what we need
out a life or feel we need out of life.
What what i'm actually doing in my life
as to where i'm putting my energies
and maybe part of
that is still creating what i was
trying to get away from before
and bringing it all here with
me and creating it again
or whether it's all actually here anyway.
And you know it's all in
there within one's own life.
It was.
I feel asian.
Well yeah if you're to go back to the
equator is still a thing because
that was some time back.
Going back 20 years ago
and then it was a period of probably 10
years before i actually started living here
in this area. And.
Eventually when i made that break and you
know came here and looked at this place.
And it was just a cattle property and
thinking god you know this looks like.
On the surface it didn't look very
good. It just looks like a paddock.
But the feeling under me.
Is there was a feeling some
feeling about it and that's
when i clicked into that's
what i like it and.
So i decided to buy
and then ended up moving here finally
breaking hours in the system
and moving here then interacting with
the land and the people i was at
that particular stage
in going through court.
You know major court case which went for
eight months in a bikini sort of like
having manages and no proper roads
and it rained for nearly
eight months just during
that so to.
Even though at times it was very testing
you think shit. When i married you were.
Well it's out there especially with
court cases and that because you think.
I came here to get away
from all that stuff
and fairly it's all here even
more so more confronted by it
but then the realisation in that is that
food like trying to avoid something
or running away from something you further
caught there you got to you have to
confront it and go through it. So
all so well that was happening.
Interacting with the land and that that
was really great and even the rain.
It was good. It was good. Walking the
land it was digging holes planting a tree
and sort of getting mud all
the dirt on your hands.
It was good school and.
Even the whole pioneering spirit
of it and the other people
that sort of moved in
and sort of just finding
out how diverse people are
and i guess the old turn ative tends
to attract people. At a very diverse.
You know. So like me they sort of.
Want to get away from a system that
tends to just clone people stereo time.
But in that diversity.
You can find five you know people can be
can sing totally different to you can have
totally different person
first section of a liar
when it comes to consensus of agreement.
And it is you know it's not there for
the other aspect of that is that.
You can learn a lot in
really start learning
and i mean you start interacting with
people these different kinds tests and.
Different ideas
and i think our yeah it's interesting.
So then getting on with a
few years after being here.
Sort of really starting to
develop in getting into the land
and going through different stages.
I would like meditating getting into a
working meditation as sort of not seeing
people for weeks on end.
And create a really good getting into
the feeling of the land of the live
or the energy or whatever you thought if
you want to call it all was brilliant.
I think those particular
that particular time.
Were was really pretty and when
i when i reflect back on it.
It was good that pathology
the feeling of it.
Ok i get up in the morning and just spend
the whole day working in the garden
and staying there until the sun went down
and even if it was rainy is
to get out there and book.
And it was a work it was
really work. It was.
It was an enjoyable doing. The mall.
Yeah just getting out there and
just working in the garden
but it wasn't really work. It was an enjoyment
it was like there was a meditation.
And so building a rock or going into
rock and i started going rock all.
And i really enjoyed
that because it's just by handling the
rock picking them up there you know they
had their different sizes different
textures feeling about it and
and the way to the right.
And also there's this feeling like
an energy you get from a rock
and it was just amazing experience
to bring you know really light.
And building the wall of birds when
you see unfinished sort of you know
when you start being creative with it
and putting patterns in
the wall of the night.
To create a great.
Thing getting into building a house.
So you can see the house and.
I guess in the beginning i used to.
I think chemo 12 is the time people are
going to build our place to wonder about
things she can i get to build a house
and i've never built a house before.
They're finally getting to a point where i
thought of you know really have to do it
had to build a house so ideas and.
So we've my particular nature
or bringing order from my manic
approach will be hazier i'm sort of
tend to be more into.
Detail and you know sort
of. Making things sort of.
So that's there is there.
The. They look for a site.
I think is a word for it and.
I suppose being particular.
And going through
that experience for a couple of years doing
it by myself because i wanted to sort
of challenge or idea of challenger was
some sort of eager thing or whatever.
Without power tools all by hand
and a helluva lot of work a lot of energy
and i used to really just myself
out at full time doing it really
frustrated sort of hitting a nail in a sort
of with the religious farmers on their.
Shoes.
You know i get really aggro about it
and throw the hammer over the roof
of really doors we jump up and down
and whatever. And it's been the rest
of the day looking for the hammer.
Mr.
I suppose it had a sense a
reward you know and movie.
I wonder about the things
we do that we don't realize
when we you know like you get
satisfaction out of it and to achievement
or whatever and i think
when you do something it someone gives
you a pat on the back in some way
that enhances you too. To make
you feel good about it and.
So there was great in people
you know even though it's good
and i think i thought
and now i look at it.
I think yeah well it's a how
they do i guess is there
but i don't really think of it that i
filled it that you know with my own sweat
and blood that went into it
and how i'd paint over it.
I sort of forgotten or i don't
want to remember all that.
I think you know like
but i don't know whether i do it
again if i did i do it differently.
I wouldn't do it but they
probably power to it.
But it hating generated.
As for now what's going on with the.
What we allot of her vehicle the next
stage of of our growth or development.
That's a good word you think
growth of better. Of the village.
Bill and will include
and it is a village natural village
with the commercial centre and and all.
And i can see that.
Yeah it's great to be good to have a
commercial centre down there abilities centres
in a commercial for a village centre
sort of like the heart of the village
and either just remind me too that.
An aspect of being in a community
and even though it's not a
commune it's a community.
Just like village of the
community but because it's.
Something about their
one part a lot of land
or whatever it is then
that if there's a binding there
it's like an extended family
and even if even if the people here
that you may never talk to you still
have this thing they're finding
and play and i think there's
a sort of interest thing
that could cause a lot of
good at that to some time.
It may not be so good
and it's sort of a.
I suppose it's there.
Yeah i think you do and maybe it's
something you sort of take to grant.
When bert.
And recently i've been looking
at what i'm doing here
and want to getting out of this place and.
If it is what are we creating it's just
that the reliever again because
they can see that here to suburbia
and the new killer family
when you go to parties
and it all revolves around
the family structure
and you know how johnny going at school
and you know when the school fete is on
and all that sort of stuff
and up to me i find
that just oriented you
know there's no there's
no definite for me really. And
specially for my radical.
And i think you know this really where i
want to be here is really right i warrant
and then looking at
that if you will. Okay.
You know that's not what i want
what i don't do something about it.
Bringing my radical side more out
expressing that and seeing what happens.
Or you know being more honest
without that a victim and by doing
that finding that the reaction coming
back is yeah why not do it. Yes but.
There are other people other energy there
that a similar one of the things thing
and i feel a need for that too.
So okay start doing that and if that
draws other energy other people that.
Feel it being then why not.
Who knows what may happen.
I suppose.
Bring it to bring out my radicalized
state of what i call radically new
concepts of the way we live.
Rather than how we've.
Brought up of conditions to feel we should
live life in this the new killer family
thing the the marriage thing the the
male female the one to one and all
that sort of stuff
that possibly.
I think there's very few people that could
really add here or find in the style
that that's where they're
that there's one to one thing
even milder female thing is
that i think very few people actually
find that totally for feeling.
But if they can just go along with
it because that's the way it is
and they see they don't question
that or they say find they can't
or they don't want to. And.
That possibly in oh i feel that in life.
If it's all interaction.
Because possibly just one
tiny is interaction and
that where is strict ing ourselves
and one to one relationship
that we're not allowing ourselves to to
interact more to experience morning life.
And things like how we
interact with people here.
If you go to a social limitations all the
time even if you may want to to feel
that you want to hear to that person
or they might to you you still
restricted by this limitation.
So you play along with that. And then coming
away from that situation and thinking.
You know i can be boring. Done that. All
before and you know you know for you.
Just not feeling something yourself
and i think it's a spiritual
aspect of yourself of life
that i should talk about myself.
Maybe i find it not for filling
in my spiritual aspect of it.
Being able to relate to the renteria.
Being a well person loads of
relating to me to my own gayness.
Maybe yes i suppose it is but
i i think even if a person
that was so caused great or heterosexual
and i think the same thing was to apply
sexuality i think we're all just a sexual
whether we're home with sexual or bisexual
or heterosexual it's all
categorizing it all label and
and sure you need to use
those words for expression
but the realisation of where it's
that is just individuality is
just individual asexual and.
I suppose for myself in
happen the question.
My own sexuality and with the
system growing up in the system
that conditions are such that
heterosexuality is how it should be and
that homosexual ideas. And bad.
You know wrong or evil or something like.
I suppose
that in itself has made me question because
i have a feeling towards something
and then at this point it telling me that
you can't do that or you shouldn't do
that it contradicts
and it's something i had to look at
in myself and come to terms with
and i suppose by that is
accepting my own sexuality. But.
And with. I mean accepted that sexuality.
Then you can either fit it into a
particular sector of the system
that is the gay ghetto or the gay movement
or you know whether it be the men's
movement or as if you are a woman with.
There will and or you don't to be mourned
with the women's movement or whatever
or whether it's capitalism or socialism
or whatever.
This is where you want to fit into
a life and i suppose coming here.
Maybe more so because of my
for my so maybe i'm more
my spiritual aspect of life of feeling
more fulfillment out of life brothers
energy.
Following a routine system that
i suppose wasn't stimulating
and i was bored with the rut.
I think that the hard way what
works for what is most spiritual
that i could say something.
Now but i could change on that
tomorrow in the next hour.
But i'm trying to find the.
Feeling of belonging integration
harmony the positive aspect
love what i consider love positive
and even for the negative aspect of life
which would come into the ages for i think
it's a question of using
words that are you.
I don't think you could you can put
your actual feeling at the fishery
and you're your spiritual aspect of
feeling into words system possible.
I don't know just to justify higher food.
I suppose it's a harmonious feeling and
that includes everything positive negative.
You know the union.
Like there's an awful feeling whole
more harmonious where there's
trees around the greenery you haven't
got a concrete jungle where it's four
corners and angles.
And you know you you you have a
system where you've got to follow
this particular line. You know if
you go down the road. You can't.
You've got you've got have taken
for you you've got to follow a
rigid rigid cord. Yeah.
Yeah and i think in
that you see you i find in myself
that it was stopping a lot of my.
And i feel it should shouldn't be the. You
know just a slight flow that there is.
But there's waves it's slow it.
Yeah right. Being gay and
being here in this place
and do include those first coming here
and moving from queensland where at the
time it was still illegal to be gay
or you know. The the laws were
still against homosexuality.
And even though i had sort of
already confronted my sexually.